we're learning terrifying new details
about a United Airlines flight that
suddenly plunged 1400 feet and was in
fact just seconds from crashing into the
Pacific Ocean all this happened shortly
after the plane took off during a storm
in Maui back in December on a flight to
San Francisco according to preliminary
data the jet fell at a rate of 8 600
feet per minute and came within 800 feet
of the ocean itself Rod Williams was on
that plane and described what happened
all of a sudden the nose pitched up
pretty pretty dramatically for maybe
three to five seconds
um and at that point there were a number
of Screams that were let out United
tells CBS News the pilots reported the
incident when they landed safely and
after an investigation they were given
more training ABS Aviation experts
credit those Pilots with avoiding a
catastrophe